[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute koche ich mit samira heute
gibt es nicht ein leckeres um schnelles
mittagsgericht wir werden spaghetti alla
potter nascar zubereiten wobei wir keine
spaghetti nehmen sondern babette das
sind so die flacheren spaghetti die
schmecken uns nämlich viel besser als
die zu dünne und spaghetti echt und ich
wusste dass all die jahre nicht okay
papa und ich also morath und ich finden
die arbeiter besser sein ihrer spaghetti
ich kaufe dir mal mit der manager
und zwar ist richtig einfach ist nun die
gericht ich will euch gar nicht sagen
was die übersetzung heißt denn die
geschichte davon ist eigentlich eine
ziemlich traurige und schnee gaal ein
leckeres nudelgericht mit einer tollen
tomatensoße sehr würzig vor allem und
ich denke wir zeigen euch mal kurz die
zutaten
wir verwenden dafür 500 gramm wette oder
spaghetti 50 gramm olivenöl 1 bis 2
knoblauchzehen und zwei zwiebeln 40
gramm oliven sind bereits entsteint 20
stellen filets die waren in öl gelegt 20
grad sind abgetropft eine prise zucker
700 gramm tomaten etwas salz und pfeffer
und petersilie
also ich mache es jetzt so ich habe
jetzt schon mal das nudelwasser
angesetzt denn so sehr geht wirklich
super schnell und ich kann schon mal die
zwiebel und knoblauchzehe schälen
die knoblauchzehe ich schneide ich jetzt
gleich in feine scheiben und samira du
kannst schon mal die cocktailtomaten
nehmen guck mal die sind ja auch schön
fest noch und die drückst einfach hier
durch und dann werden sie hatten
gefürchtet und geachtet wird uns jetzt
achte luxo und dann zack das darfst du
machen
da könnte ich auch nicht schneiden super
und so kannst du die ganzen tomaten
schneiden ohne deine finger zu schneiden
[Musik]
ich kann das hier schon mal das olivenöl
erhitzen das mache ich jetzt ja auch
stufe 8 also fast auf höchster stufe und
mittel hoch und dann kann ich zwiebeln
hier in feine würfel schneiden und die
knoblauchzehe das ist echt eine große
daher nehme ich nur eine oder knoblauch
sehr einfach in scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
okay ich gehe jetzt schon mal rüber zum
öl bevor es zu heiß wird und gebe jetzt
hier die zutaten rein
jetzt trotzdem das brauche ich nicht
mehr die oliven habe ich nämlich schon
entstand und fein geschnitten
ich nehme schon mal alle zutaten mit
herüber und kann jetzt die zwiebel mit
der knoblauchzehe anschwitzen
bis die zwiebel einfach schön glas ich
ist ich hab ich dann doch ein bisschen
runter gestellt gusseisen speichert die
hitze ja sehr daher braucht ihr da nicht
auf volle pulle zu kochen sondern nehmt
einfach wirklich nur geringe hitze ich
gebe jetzt hier auch ein bisschen den
deckel drauf dann kann man die zwiebeln
knoblauch sehr schön schmoren
es ist wirklich so ein rezept da seid
ihr in locker 20 minuten fertig und
könnte direkt öffnen
jetzt kommt hier die sardellenfilets
dazu die dürfen dann gerne so ein
bisschen nun zerschmelzen in der pfanne
die geben halt wirklich den tollen
geschmack also sardellen sind wirklich
der uebler geschmacksträger
ich nehme auch pizza mit sattel und wenn
sie hier in der soße verkochen dann
spürt man auch gar nichts mehr davon
also wirklich gut man sei nicht wichtig
ach das waren so frauen diamant hart
gearbeitet und dann war da noch und er
hat sich gedacht mensch die machen so
eine harte körperliche arbeit die stärke
ich mit einem schnellen mittagessen ja
das war es eigentlich nur traurig weil
die frau so viel gearbeitet haben dass
sie sonst eben nie essen hatten
erklärt
so jetzt kommen hier noch die karten mit
rein die dürfen gerne weglassen wenn ihr
keine mögt dann deine tomaten perfekt
geachtet alle mit rein
mit sich dass hier köcheln gemeinsam mit
einer prise zucker salz und pfeffer
kommen pfeiffer ja dann gibt's immer so
ein bisschen sogar noch das 2
beim salzen aufpassen denn die sardellen
und die körpern sind aufsätze als sich
also lieber gleich nochmal abschmecken
und dann kommt hier der deckel drauf die
soße darf könnte
und jetzt kann ich im prinzip die nudeln
insgesamt sind der nudel wasser dann
geben
die oliven geben wir auch schon mal dazu
jetzt kocht das wasser hier schon jetzt
das salz dazugeben und wirklich nur die
wasser erst dann salzen wenn es kocht
nicht weil es dann schneller kopf
sondern weil ihr eure daten schützt denn
wenn das salz ins kalte wasser kommt
schwimmt das salz am boden und das
beschädigt eure köpfe auf dauer ok und
jetzt die spaghetti super wetter
[Musik]
und jetzt haben wir zeit aufzuräumen
denn die eine okay die eine richtung
versöhnlich deckel wieder drauf jetzt
aber zeit hier kurz aufzuräumen richten
schon mal den teller denn sobald die
nudeln gar sind werden sie mit als
referent bundes essen ist bereit ein
schnelles gericht gelb
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt machen für den tennis in
die gans mini und wir haben wir jetzt
eine vermischung und dies unbewusst und
davon gebe ich jetzt nach gefühl war ein
ja ich mache geforderter namen
reingebissen ausgefallen
und ja also was machen wir immer mit
bananen wenn sie zu reif sind ein
einfrieren und dann haben wir immer
gefroren oder bananen sind und zwar von
augenbrauen arbeit es ist nur schade so
danach kommt man rein und dann haben
hier noch mandeln eingeweiht denn daraus
machen wir mandelmilch aber wir müssen
uns jetzt einfach mit dem smoothie
[Musik]
wie viel macht jetzt geht jetzt eher
mehr um den mandeln
so und jetzt kann ich einfach mit wasser
auffüllen und die man dann kann man
später mit dem wasser vermitteln und
haben dann einfach mandelmilch und
kaltes wasser jahre rohstoff und wird
zur schwachen liter smoothie ok komm
mach noch minister rhein
hast du hebst oben also m
wir haben jetzt noch paar minzblättern
betreiben kann schwimmstil rein
ich nehme so ein bisschen nudelwasser
die nudeln sind jetzt al dente und wir
können gleich essen
das sehen wir uns kurz auf nudeln
schnell abgießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das eidg
[Musik]
perfekt
und typisch italienisch vermischen wir
jetzt die nudeln direkt mit der suche
ich lass dir ein paar übrig aber du
probierst auch okay
[Musik]
und fertig
so kommt er macht nur noch deine
smoothie fertig und dann probieren wir
gleich und hier dürfte jetzt keinen
parmesan benutzen denn parmesan und
fisch darf nicht vermischt werden also
kein käse und fisch vermischen ist in
italien verboten
ein sakrileg habe ich gelesen todsünde
aber ich es gerne meinen ex model mit am
samstag
und wenn ihr jetzt noch braucht könnt
ihr gerne noch nudelwasser verwenden
aber meine so weit so eigentlich schon
schön sich auch zum probieren
[Musik]
oder 1000 100 milliliter ok 1100 und
dennis kock darfst rubin unserem ära wir
probierten unsere spaghetti familie hat
was für dich gemacht was denn das passt
zu dem karohemd wasser drin man meinen
doch und ich stehe hier noch petersilie
drüber ich mich gut so google darf ich
auch probieren der banane hätte man noch
nehmen können für die süße aber
erfrischend dass sie versuchen noch ein
paar blätter minze zu bekommen samira
ist probiert die starke tier ohne dich
wenn es das sind allen drin sonst hätte
ich dich probieren lassen die schönsten
übung die ohren nudeln tor stand ich
mach dir gleich noch eine version ohne
sattel ich probier mal nudeln wir machen
gleich noch was oder ohne kann frau wir
mal den boden
ja sie will die von der note probieren
probieren vor lecker bisschen salz fehlt
noch
aber dieses gericht könnt ihr wirklich
jederzeit sofort zubereiten sind ganz
einfaches und schnelles mittag oder
abendessen und schmeckt mir sehr gut die
auch eine vermutung mit so sind um die
schöne würze kommt echt durch die satten
also probiert gerne aus schreibt mir was
eure lieblings mittagessen und was eure
lieblings rezepte sind dann mache ich
die auch gerne nach und wenn ihr mehr so
schnelle rezepte sehen wollt schreibt
auf
also bis zum nächsten mal jetzt gehen
wir essen aber am tisch
[Musik]